[музика]
війна в Україні уперше безпосередньо
зачепила країну члена НАТО від
польського селища пшеводу близько 5
кілометрів до українського кордону за 10
кілометрів проходить лінія якою Україна
експортувала електроенергію до Польщі до
російських атак по енергосистемі
напередодні ракета влучила у місцеві
зерносушарки двоє людей загинули
я побігла до вікна Вибух пролунав
недалеко метрів за 100 я побачила
величезну хмару чорного страшного диму
якщо не помиляюся ще бачила вогонь
скоріш за все загорілися лінії
електропередач
електричних у Вечірньому зверненні у
вівторок Володимир Зеленський назвав
інцидент суттєвою ескалацією закликав
НАТО до дій і наголосив що по Польщі
вдарили російські ракети водночас і
польський президент Анджей Дуда і генсек
НАТО йенс толтенберг Наступного дня
заявили що ознак цілеспрямованого
обстрілу Польщі Росією немає
розслідування інциденту триває нам варто
дочекатися висновків Але у нас немає
ознак того що це результат навмисною
атаки також немає ознак того що Росія
готується до наступальних дій проти НАТО
за даними попереднього аналізу інциденту
спровокований ракетою української ППО
яка захищала українську територію від
російського ракетного обстрілу Дозвольте
наголосити це не вина України
речник повітряних сил України Юрій Гнат
у коментарі де покликав дочекатися
результатів розслідування і розглянути
різні версії на його думку якщо ракету
випустили з Росії То цей удар не міг
бути випадковим адже РФ вбила
напередодні досить точними ракетами Юрій
Гнат не виключає що теоретично влучити
могла і ракета української ППО зрозуміло
що може бути балістична траєкторія тут
це техніка це Техніка не нова вона може
і бути І таке але але
ракета зенітна якщо втрачає ціль з
інтеркети S300 чи Booking М1 вона
передбачений механізм самоліквідації це
треба теж брати до вас деякі українські
експерти зазначають що українська влада
поспішила заявити що ракета прилетіла в
Польщу з Росії політолог Ігор Чаленко
так не вважає На його думку Володимир
Зеленський заявляв про приліт російської
ракети після консультації з військовими
всю правду дізнаються наші союзники але
за закритими дверима тому що ми
розуміємо якщо офіційно
Сполучені Штати Америки або інші країни
блоку НАТО зараз напряму заявлять А що
це був збройний напад російською
російською Федерації то звичайно
постане питання загалом єдності позиції
всередині блоку на ми бачимо такі країни
наприклад як Туреччина якугорщина тому я
думаю що поки немає оцієї єдності
всередині блоку в публічній сфері не
будуть поспішати
однозначно казати що це Атака Російської
Федерації а набагато легше дійсно це
списати нібито це робота української ППО
поки ж в західні союзники єдині у тому
що ракета б не залетіла на територію
НАТО якби не війна Росії проти України
Про це заявили у Великобританії
Нідерландах Німеччині звідки б не був
завданий удар по Польщі Він на цьому
Росія певенний аналітик Макс Бергман
Я думаю незважаючи ні на що Росія не з
тими відповідальність Росія обстрілює
українську територію крилатими ракетами
якщо українська протиповітряна оборона
дійсна влучила не туди як стверджують
росіяни що на мою думку не зовсім
вірогідно Але якщо це так то все одно Я
не з тими відповідальність тому що вона
атакує іншу країну і запускає ракети по
суверенній державі на думку британського
військового експерта майка Мартіна
влучання ракет на території сусідніх з
Україною держав було неминучим водночас
це може бути і приводом до подальшої
ескалації
і з самого початку війни обидві сторони
і Росія і НАТО докладали всіх зусиль аби
конфлікт не виходив за межі України
заклики закритого неба були відкинуті
ядерні погрози Росії так само адже хоч
війна в Україні і жахлива більш
масштабний конфлікт - це повна
катастрофа цей останній інцидент двоє
загиблих громадян держави-члена НАТО тут
уже обом сторонам складніше говорити про
дескалацію і стримуванню конфлікту в
межах українських кордонів
аналітики єдині у тому що після удару по
Польщі допомога Україні від західних
партнерів лише посилиться не виключають
і більше Радикальної реакції але вже за
результатами розслідування
насправді На мою думку це призведе до
більшої підтримки України та збільшення
готовності можливо надати Україні певну
зброю яку захід ще не надавав і до
подальшого збільшення підтримки України
в цьому конфлікті і це також може
призвести до того що Білорусь може
отримати застереження або навіть і удар
у відповідь по своїй території якщо
російські сили насправді випустили
ракети з Білорусі по території НАТО
тим часом на тлі влучання ракети у
Польщі збираються уже 7 засідання
контактної групи з оборони України у
форматі Rammstein реагуючи на інцидент у
Польщі президент Литви закликав посилити
протиповітряну оборону НАТО на східних
кордонах а Прем'єр Канади по більше
підтримки українським збройним силам